you're watching the GameSpot stage
brought to you by airhead 3 2016 that
we're on the GameSpot stage here brought
to you by airheads I'm very happy to be
joined by harada-san we are looking at
Tekken 7 Michael Murray thank you so
much for coming along great to have you
guys here
Tekken 7 has been available in the
arcades for quite a while now go with
the municipality yeah actually it's been
out for over a year so far and we
actually have an update plan for the
arcades coming July next month is that
an important process of making these
games is getting them out to the fans
who really want to sort of dive into
them and getting that initial feedback
for the wider console my first look to
him until he'd walk with us walk do your
thing I wanna see my opera
I know give me all day it ethically aqui
tenemos una more cansado Bonnie tried
associate a juvenile jujitsu scenarios
related to business environment there MA
I know who my mother cake was a walk for
the last year remark but it'll suck you
don't know well it's important for
various reasons one is like you said the
feedback to receive on the bounce of the
game when there are fans like etc but
also people maybe don't realize that it
generates quite a lot of profits so
right off it allows us to actually pull
into the game for the console version to
add all the bonus features and such that
people like so much it's proved to be
very good for us so far but you know I
don't know if that's something we'll be
continuing the feature it depends on the
state of our case right okay are we are
you seeing the same sort of decline in
Japan in the arcades ad don't worry
staggering Keiko Hedy Lamarr's yeah okay
yeah a new home Wow
hey you gonna convert Amana wha da hood
ornament yeah I think we've seen kind of
a drop in the decline there was a pretty
steady drop there for a while but he
spot him out of bed okay that said you
know parts of Asia Oceania
they're doing a lot better I think the
way right yeah I'm certainly it's great
we have here we're playing Tekken 7 here
some very familiar characters Akuma here
in hi Hachi how is the game differed for
people who haven't played in the arcades
who haven't got a chance to do it how is
it different to Tekken 6 which is it's
almost a decade since we played that and
I Coronado mom what's wrong
a toe touch it the top row they talk
monolithic you know they know my motto
Eden is giving more at a game system
taking on cotton swab rescue talk
economist cash capital huntin apples the
Sakuni
quite a Toto cyrillic often on Avenue D
cocked on also most facilitative they
are that operates the rival Tarot 2018
iPhoto pinch not open e a Kovac techne I
didn't dr. Herrera so usually they
reported a sequel mom quarter nice to
corral Kiko right now someone else maybe
not even ATO it's quite different you
know a lot of people like to say all
fighting games have never changed or
evolved etcetera right but if you look
at the game compared to six as you said
it is quite different you know the
inclusion of Akuma and his
characteristics and fighting mechanics
and such but also in general the
addition of gameplay features such as
rage Drive rage arts these kind of
things that are kind of things you see
more in 2d fighters have been
transitioned well I think to the 3d
fighter tuck-in they kind of make it
more impactful easier to come back from
behind this if you're in a pinch but
also it's just more accessible as a
whole I think to general audience yeah
almost
Tony might cause she's in Wow
if a meter is Tomoyuki the Gideons know
about hi Lakota Akiko hit a good idea at
conservator a Tokyo through to Virginia
without the Sadako honey moon coming
back to pass throws open up their own
phalanges Cocteau Sabadell keratosis
What's Wrong little monster are you
depression after the other time we need
it all positive system it also move
whatever go today
it operates ergometer some dots the
pontiff are not you know they took it to
solution consulate in there so again so
Tai Chi double my money laughter music
Vikki a monoatomic so season and this
feature just mentioned where we're
included obviously to make it more
accessible but also to make the game
more fun to watch for people who aren't
playing the game right and this is also
goes even further with the slowdown
gameplay mechanics you might see when
either of you has like a little sliver
of health and you're both attacking you
don't know who's going to connect you
get the slow-motion effect so if you
know like box from other fighting actual
sports yeah you see that kind of a
replay after the match but this actually
happens in real time when most players
are doing their attacks it adds a new
level excitement to the mass before the
actual outcome is decided I'm pretty
curious where you believe Tekken fits
inside of the the world of fighting
games because these days so many games
are designed for competitive scenes
right but there are a lot of casual
players are still like it how do you
balance those two play styles when
developing a game that has such a deep
mechanics like Tekken arcade over based
or not you know they're good quality
Haku budino a party to toe and opieop ow
hold on I have to get back to you cannot
game continued some cascara McCory
night so that japanese is
the result all it took until they
achieve Konoha I know eSports after
Sultan caster our cadeau de ichiban
Mariota so energy Katie's gonna see
Moses taking apart that one wanted
cotton fighting illness it's raw
material only you know walk in and
evaporate story mundo de Kaap atomic a
moral purpose to redeem us with mooskaa
cures over hominid demo talisman with an
autonomous avocado co coco gravity
returns on the game consist makin given
a punkin system okay they'll talk with a
nice so you know taking actually there's
a lot of talk about eSports and
competitive play sense but ticking
actually we date back to the arcade
roots and that's where that playing 100
yen you know about $1 for play is what
really fundamentally changed the game
system because you have to be satisfied
with the result of that match it has to
be fair to you as a player and that's
kind of what kind of built on that later
what would become eSports and such so
that is geared towards not just the the
hardcore but also the casual fan as well
that sense of satisfaction with the
results view and then again for the the
casual fan you we also try to include
these elements such as the story mode
and other features that are kind of
separate from that one-on-one experience
that's it to also please an enhanced
experience would you say Akuma
represents part of that effort as well
because he seems to have mechanics that
are very different from the rest of the
characters including a super bar on
Annie X bar are those moves did they
give him an advantage in a certain way
or is he fairly well balanced among the
whole
I told you to other Amina McKinney
Saroja dokkan dokkan are you forbid or
battle-ax engages opportunity for you go
home I want to go and marriage and stuff
so quani did wanted to take a model the
Bema got a little mistake sorry okay
okay Atari at all you could return a lot
more people a job to polish the rival
new ya tebya photo you want okay you
wanna do number one on there supposin I
coulda seen anything new Ciro don't go
to the bull you can to put job Tuesday
to become very difficult for Maria and I
walkie the Attwater can open it - stop -
no animation cuckoo cuckoo shigani
although you who need scary Komatsu
Melissa Billy Cochran Avenue Dino
Juergen autoplay videos dual air
Catahoula cuckoo musica SCOTUS
give me the Sun across a nice that's a
good question because a lot of people
think that you know he has projectiles
and such and his his gameplay might make
him more effective than other technique
Eric Turner but that's not the case you
know we've always had characters had
laser beams and such and there's a
sidestep to avoid them so again this
super moves etc I kind of roughly
translated into what other techniques
characters might be able to do with her
rage drives where the rage arts attacks
so we feel he's not that unbalanced the
thing that we really actually kind of
had a bit of trouble with developing him
was more the look in the feel of him you
know trying to make an extra feel
realistic as a 2d fighter and you know
they called the stop it like when you do
like a dragon punch and it kind of goes
along boom that kind of feel to it and
also the control to it was something
that we struggled to get right how hard
is it to actually fit him in as a
personality and in the cast of Tekken
month ago
does it go beyond money money taka-kun
or not produce at all
solitare conservative story tight
acrostic game on optimist good judgment
on [ __ ] in a mocha nominal they took
the sloped idea wanted a pair of
Tottenham 32 adapted to the dino-duelist
we gingerly can't even cover Motorola
MOTO interest in Nepal karamakov
pin one idea of the Superbird it's a
story that some minor changes so no idea
after their community mu 0 so regard
Cara do some gokyo who got Azalea tight
you know
Hoboken na na Nana Michael you need to
get a tunnel there so a congregate I've
seen dick stop you know I mean you have
to smooth sneaky bastard
actually the initial discussions with
the onus on I guess I'd go back to maybe
seven years ago you know when they just
first started on the street fighter
cross tekken see the game we were
discussing ways to kind of make a very
good sound collaboration with the 2d and
3d fighters and you know naturally that
kind of focuses on the game system right
if I was thinking he really wants to tie
it in with the story to do something go
beyond just the gameplay mechanics and
look at the character so that kind of
early inspiration was there from you
know that period which was seven years
or so ago and to accomplish that go Voki
are aqua at the West was kind of a
perfect vehicle I guess you could say
for that and as such you know he was
very easy to implement into the whole
Tekken environment the atmosphere
and the storyline so he was the perfect
choice up there I'll be easier than
zonkey last question I guess you talked
about how financial you know the success
of the arcade was instrumental in Tekken
7 and if TECA and 7 does really well on
consoles will you go back to Ono and
talk about second cross street fighter
when we see it again it will the King
Cotton Council shiitakes an actor a Toto
see me at school it should get it on the
map ending seriously you are pursuit of
a Tarleton katabatic estate a similar
image Johnny Musso Johnny Maria da
dictator the kong-chi dado community
college so why don't you talk about a
timing cause you know there it or it was
a canary
biddies emoticons and kept Inanna
odorous able to look on your taste 100
1000 server core security no more jumar
you know model that's actually a very
good question because taking across
Street Fighter is not canceled its kind
of put on hold and the reasons are kind
of you know right now Street Fighter 5
is just launched Capcom explaining and
tremendous effort into making that
successful on our side you know we
released Tekken 7 in the arcade working
on the update it was even more popular
than we even imagined and so we each
have these two main franchises we're
trying to promote and have the players
enjoy at the moment so you know
business-wise it's not a very good
decision but then throwing another one
to the mix so as you say if Tekken 7
does extremely well on sweet by the 5
and they're on a good
maybe there's a timely way to want to
maybe revisit that conversation cool
in the meantime Tekken 7 coming out soon
in Japan very soon on consoles and 2017
over here right
Japan is only an arcade ok and for next
month and then consoles is early 2017
wonderful Hirata sound team as well and
Steve as well how that sound thank you
very much for time like a pleasure and
thank you all so much for watching we'll
be back in just a couple of minutes here
on the GameSpot stage next up is Dead
Rising for just talking about cop-con
let's get them on in a few minutes
cigarette